Well,
leaders of the school board will
meet today to discuss
mandatory vaccinations for
university and college employees. How are you
greeted by Cristian Cáceres? A week ago,
state legislators rejected
having to force
Nevada students to be vaccinated against Kobe 19
This allows those who are not
vaccinated to enroll in their
classes for the next two months. The classes
begin on January 18 and I
tell you that on December 26 the police
of geniuses say that the drivers
of these vehicles that they have on their
screen vandalized  mission
hills park located on college drive
and highway 95 at least four
vehicles damaged the land of this
park the police managed to arrest one
of the suspects a 17-
year-old teenager and the passenger the authorities are
still on the trail of the others
involved
and I tell them that they give to motown they want to
organize the event home for the holiday  s
this means there is no
adoption fee for only animals
over 6 months old this special ends
on Friday adoption is available
on a first come first served basis so no
appointment is needed and we close this report with
a look at the temperatures as you
can see there  a
winter storm warning until
4pm on friday we can see
some showers peaking in the
50s now the night to ring in the
new year will be cold by 8
expect about 46 degrees around
midnight it drops to 42 there will be  also
winds of 15 miles per hour this is
really going to be the situation a little
colder than normal i am cristian
casseres with super informative from
spanish kirchner good day